[Music]
hey guys before I start with today's
topic I wanna announce the giveaway we
will be giving away a $20 Amazon gift
cards at the end of the next week all
you have to do is be subscribed to our
channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the
comments section after a bunch of
teasers promotion photos and after the
tentative poster that HBO published
yesterday the official trailer for
season 7 has finally been released a few
hours ago while there are no words to
describe this trailer it completely left
me speechless and an anxiety of waiting
for a new season in this video it will
be introduced to detailed shot by shot
analysis of the official trailer there
are a lot of details that are not
visible at the first glance details that
you might have missed so without further
due let's just jump into it it all
starts with Cersei walking through the
red key towards the giant map of
Westeros with her speech in her speech
with presumably Jaime she says enemies
to the east while as soon as she says
that we got a shot of grey worm
commander of the unsullied accompanied
with elite warrior eunuchs meaning that
Cersei is clearly referring to the
nearest Targaryen entered two armies
along with her three giant dragons that
tool and the dragon stone on the east
coast of Westeros in the first episode
of the upcoming season in the next shot
we can see the table in the chamber of
the painted table the main hole in the
castle of Dragonstone which is actually
named after the table that dominates the
roam carved in shape of Westeros and
engraved with its major cities and
landmarks this table we have already
seen in the second season as Stannis
Baratheon held meetings with his court
in that room and also had intimate
relations with Melisandre on that same
table
however shot of the table is also
accompanied with Cersei speech now
saying enemies to the west
referring on the reach one of the larger
regions of the Seven Kingdoms that is
ruled from the castle of Highgarden by
house Tyrell as well now Cersei almost
completely destroys house Tyrell by
blowing up the great Sept of Baelor
living alone as the sorcerer
while house Tyrell who is now seeking
for a revenge and his back in the season
6 finale pledged her house to support
House Targaryen and the nurses claim to
the Iron Throne the following shot most
likely provides us the first official
look of your Aegis infamous long ship
silence that is most likely sailing
towards the fleet battle that will take
place in the first episodes of the
upcoming season Yara and Theon supported
by then is Li the same snakes are going
to try to retake the Iron Islands from
urine and this is most likely I shall
take in a few moments before the actual
battle starts then again we get a shot
of the painted table that is again a
company that serves his speech now
saying enemies to the South referring to
the southernmost part of Westeros that
is now ruled over by larious and under
the leadership of Illyria sand and sand
snakes the forces of house Martell and
don't have a lines of support and
heiresses cause against House Lannister
is they declared war against them while
both sides and sand snakes and the
Lannisters are seeking revenge against
each other
the sand snakes want vengeance for the
deaths of various members of house
Martell the death of Oberyn Martell in
the first place well Cersei wants to
avenge the death of her daughter then
for a moment you can see a shot of a
person sharpen the sword while the
identity is unknown this shot refers to
the fact that the tensions are high and
that the 7th season will be the season
of war of numerous battles that we're
developing throughout the previous
seasons but all of them will take place
now in the 7th season then once again we
get to see the painted table still
accompanied with Cersei speech who is
now saying enemies to the north
referring to the united north under the
lead of the new king jon snow but also
referring to the Vale of the Vale Lords
join the northern Lords in declaring Jon
Snow the king in the north
the following shot contains Arya Stark
mounted on horse finally heading home
but is most likely still somewhere in
the Riverlands then we get to see Cersei
and Jaime Lannister watching over a
dozen so feet long giant map of Westeros
again accompanies it searched his speech
whatever stands in our way and then shot
switches over to close-up of Circe's
face that Cersei says we will defeat it
the next shot contains Lannister army
most probable
led by Jaime Lannister marching towards
their enemies while the certain location
on which Lannister armies marching
remains unknown based on leaked photos
and on a few facts they're most probably
marching on Highgarden if you're
wondering why are they going to attack
Highgarden the answer is pretty simple
so let's just put it this way beside the
most important purpose besides throwing
their enemy and decreasing the nurses
strength by conquering Highgarden
Cersei with also conquering born
crossroads a major passage linking old
town and King's Landing
besides fact the reach is the most
fertile part of Westeros has rich fields
and was also provisioning food to the
capital something that Cersei lost by
killing almost every member of house
Tyrell in the third season Margaery
perhaps even foreshadow of this assault
on Highgarden
as she reminded serchio of the
importance of house Tyrell support in
the war as the reach provided food to
the capital the following shot is
definitely interesting as it contains a
person whose identity is unknown as you
can see Jaime the mountain in a few
Lannister soldiers are protecting the
new queen but the identity of a person
that is clearly having a personal
meeting with sources unknown or at least
is not certain however there are two
possibilities that man is either randyll
Tarly or urine Greyjoy as both of them
will join their forces with Cersei will
pledge their army to her cause randyll
Tarly will become Circe's ally a little
bit before urine well at first it sounds
extremely surprising as house Tarly of
horn Hill is among the houses that's
very filthy to house Tyrell of
Highgarden effects that that the head of
house Tarly Randall has always been
loyal towards Lord paramount of the
reach but his always despised her all
women now that all male Tyrells are
killed Olenna Tyrell is left as the sole
member and ruler of house Tyrell
along with the fact that randyll Tarly
has always despised Tyrell women this
alliance between Lannisters and the
tireless after all is not that
surprising Randall would become new
Lords paramount of the reach which would
place his house among other Great Houses
of the Seven Kingdoms
while Cersei beside decreasing Daenerys
strength would ensure the provision of a
food to the capital which is of the
great importance in
the time of war this alliance as it has
been confirmed by a bunch of leaked
photos will result with their march on
Highgarden and eventually with them
conquering it as it has also been
confirmed by a bunch of leaked photos
however judging by the following shot
judging by Jamie's face it is most
likely the person that is having a
meeting with Sir sees your greyjoy
utterance plan of marrying and joining
Daenerys with his fleet failed upon his
niece and nephew made a deal with Dany
urine will not give up on his intentions
of marrying a queen while it's confirmed
that upon destroying our essence and
snakes forces in a fleet battle he will
join forces with Cersei they most
probably won't only be allies there will
be a marriage between those two you have
to know that urine will not pledge his
forces to Cersei in the first part of
season 7 since urine is known for his
cunning skills meaning that he will be
aware of a fact that Cersei will not
need him in the very beginning since she
will have her new ally tireless and her
lover and brother Jaime as a general of
Lannister army it's not that Cersei
won't need yearns forces not to mention
that she needs new allies now more than
ever but she wanted this point be
desperate accept youonce army supported
at a marriage deal and urine knows that
let's get a little bit further into the
official trailer as it also supports
this possibility a little bit later in
the trailer we get to see the Trekkie
horse mounted warriors engaging the
battle along with Daenerys riding dragon
that's a moment in the Jaime with
Lannister army along with Randall and
his Tarly army will get ambushed while
they're marching home with carriages
full of gold floated from Highgarden on
their way home they're going to be
ambushed by Daenerys riding dragon along
with her the track ich werde Cersei will
manage to conquer Highgarden and to
decrease the nares to strength but the
nurse will not just sit around and watch
the nurse will take an opportunity to
fight them on the open field while Jamie
and Randall with their army start
heading home and the most certainly vain
since no army can stand a chance against
the Trekkie on the open field Robert
Baratheon said Cersei
only a fool would me to track he on an
open field and 4shared of this battle in
the very first season however added
sponsors will be desperate
there are enemies all around her and her
li will be lost
while her army will not be powerful
enough to destroy all of her enemies at
the moment which urn will have to take
the advantage of that his opportunity to
marry a queen and if leaked photos are
confirming that's an opportunity which
journal take the advantage of that the
moment Imogen will come to King's
Landing after he successfully defeat
Sierra along with the sand snakes in the
fleet battle general comments paraded
his prisoners all the way to the Red
Keep and is going to pledge his army in
the iron fleet to Cersei but in return
search people had to marry him similar
deal as he had for Daenerys well we can
see in the following shot that Jamie
surprised and convinced that Cersei will
reject your ins offer
the next shot shot Cersei who is not too
happy by this offer she is considering
it for a moment
that's the deal with her she will accept
that the deal with Cersei knows she has
to accept otherwise her reign is over
this Circe's shot is also accompanied
with her speech now saying beardless
Lannisters which then switches to Tyrion
and Cersei continues the last one's
account this reminds us once again that
Tyrion is not fighting for the
Lannisters and more even though he's the
Lannister himself the end of Cersei
speech is also revealing that she will
speak into her brother this whole time
Jaime as she said we're the Lannisters
the last ones who count utter sirs his
speech and humor shot that mostly
included either her or her speech the
trailer stretch is done under Queen
Daenerys which shot of her finally for
the first time seeing the place she was
born on the nurse's speech starts to the
close-up of her face while looking on
the castle that is entirely dominated by
dragon motifs and reliefs Daenerys says
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
while she finished the sentence in
another two shots with and I will the
following shot again includes Daenerys
this time sitting on the Iron Throne in
the dragons from throne room the next
three shots are showing the unsullied
conquering the ancestral stronghold of
House Lannister that is located on the
western coast of Westeros Casterly Rock
living Cersei without an opportunity to
seek refuge and run over there one then
I decide to attack the King's Landing
this was actually foreshadowed by Daario
naharis in the final episode of the
sixth season the side revealing his
commanding skills and his brilliant
strategy mind in his last scene which he
was left behind
he also foreshadow this the nurses
conquer over Casterly Rock upon any
statement that he is not coming with her
and her armies diary replied with new
strategy you won the second son's to
attack from West curls to take Casterly
Rock
so that Lannisters would have nowhere to
run in the following shot against the
Jon Snow having a meeting with father
Norton Lords and other important people
while in the background they can hear
the king in the north from the season 6
finale in the next shot you can once
again see Jon Snow having already
mentioned meeting on which they will
most probably discuss the fate of the
treasonous northern houses well there
also starts Littlefinger speech Petyr
Baelish says the censor your father and
brothers are gone yet here you stand
either reminding her that her father and
brothers are gone because of the
Lannisters and yet here she stands
without trying to persuade Jon into
attacking the Lannisters or it is just
the first part of the sentence as a few
months later he continues his speech in
the following shot we can see an outer 4
inch take cold rolled steel gate opening
which is in my opinion opening for bran
stark and mirror read but those are just
my thoughts it could also be Rangers by
the returning or going north of the wall
and arranging let me get a shot of team
Greyjoy who is on a boat and is most
probably in the heat of the battle
against your Greyjoy in the next shot
against email Sanjoy watching over
someone at Dragonstone while at the
first glance we would think the most
andrei upon being exiled from the north
will find a new promised hero in
Daenerys
as she is a Dragonstone we are probably
wrong
Melisandre is most likely Dragonstone
only because of Jon Snow who will arrive
over there in the first episodes of the
upcoming season to meet with the nearest
meaning that she still thinks that Jon
is the prince that was promised it's
also important to highlight that those
shots of Tiana miss Angie are
accompanied with Littlefinger speech he
says and most likely continues the same
sentence that he said
so a few moments ago he said your father
and brothers are gone yet here you stand
and now continuous with last best hope
against the coming storm
the Baelish finishes his speech with the
coming storm we get a shot of the voice
charging towards something or someone
then we can see Aria probably somewhere
in the Riverlands while her breast
implies that the winter Chili's here the
following shot includes probably a group
of people rather than the whites which
is supporting a theory the jumps from
elite group of people beyond the wall in
order to catch a white and proved an
heiress and everyone else that real war
is in the north this shot as well as a
shot of Littlefinger is now a company in
with Davos Seaworth speech Dallas says
if we don't put aside our enmity and
band together we will die speech that
he's most probably giving to the nearest
while he and John are having a meeting
with her at Dragonstone meanwhile there
are also a few shots of the tracky that
I have already explained so let's focus
on the next shot Davos Seaworth speech
continues with the next shot of the flip
barrow fiar arthéon and sand snakes
against young ray Joe and his thousand
ships that he started building in the
previous season he continues with and
then it doesn't matter whose skeleton
sits on the Iron Throne while during his
speech we also get to see close-up shot
of him as well as the shot of the
nearest cent here in the main hall of
cash for a dragon stone beside the new
look of the Queen's Guard we can also
see Jon Snow throwing little finger
against the ball in the crypts of
Winterfell which I'm mostly excited
about to find out what exactly led John
to act as he does in that shot then we
can see more shots of the unsullied
pouring in the Lannister stronghold and
battling against Lannister soldiers
there's also shot off are you looking
for something mini to bed probably for
something that she hid a few years ago
meaning that she is most likely home in
Winterfell there's also a little bit of
Jerrod to be exact we can only see his
hand providing us a clearer information
he has to find a cure for his disease as
soon as possible which he most likely is
doing at that particular moment then we
get to see more attractive warriors
engaging the battle while the following
shot is the most exciting shot in the
entire trailer Jon Snow and tour
ermand are running beyond the wall from
the whites this is once again confirming
that John will lead a small group of men
beyond the wall in order to capture
white but they will be ambushed by the
night king and his army as we can see in
this shot the next door shuts revealing
intimate relations between gray warm and
sandy and between our Greyjoy and
delirious and the last shot includes
Daenerys mounted on dragon along with
her the tracking horde marching towards
the enemy while the trailer ends with
Jon Snow statements or more accurately
warning the Great War is here and as
always let me know your opinion about
all of this in the comment section down
below I'm curious what your thoughts are
about this trailer that HBO finally
released I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next piece
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]